right now I have a half day rule one
half day a week it has to fit in that if
it can't then I can't do it my goal down
the line is make that one day a week and
that's how I've done my whole with the
podcast everything else it's whatever
fits in a half day a week that I put
aside on my calendar that's what I can
do and as I get good at something we
hire people to do something that frees
up more time I can try to add something
else but I'm constrained by that because
I think like you I would find misery if
every single day it was like we're Rock
and rolling let's go so for me it's like
okay one half day a week all in what can
we do with that get better improve this
hire that let's fix this and outside of
that I don't want to think about the
business because I think I'm with you
and that's the compromise I've come up
with